Twitch, komm'on brah, lass mich jetzt nicht hängen.
Nein, ich muss nicht warten bis ich freigeschaltet werde.
Das ist immer instant oder gar nicht.
Alter Twitch, ich krieg' Anfälle.
Was soll denn der Scheiß?
Lass mich in 1080p streamen, was soll das denn?
Leute, ich starte das jetzt so oft neu bis 1080p darf, ja?
Ich darf immer 1080p streamen.
Warum darf ich heute nicht 1080p streamen?
Was ist das?
Der Discord-Bot, der ist voll am Abkacken jetzt.
Okay, maybe dangerous MonkaS, ob ich das wirklich runterladen soll.
Kann man sich irgendwo die Bitrate anzeigen lassen?
Video-Stats.
Bitrate, Playbackrate, komm'on, das klingt zu niedrig.
Zackt.
Normalerweise ist das instant da.
Ah, easy, jetzt geht's.
Okay, ich hab' nix gesagt.
Hä, das dauert nie so lang.
Was ist das für ein Crap?
Na ja gut, ich will mich nicht beschweren.
Hauptsache es geht, easy, erst fuck.
So, das ist jetzt übrigens gerade der offizielle Stream, der hier läuft.
Aber wir installieren den Kram schonmal.
Wer weiß, was ich mir jetzt für 30 Milliarden Viren da einfange.
Also, wir gucken erstmal, was ist denn das hier?
Erstmal ein.NET-Decompiler holen, gucken was da drinne ist.
Ah, excellent, excellent. Irgendwas wie ein Binary-Geschäft.
Strings, aha, aha. So, so.
Okay, ich glaub' denen einfach mal, dass alles in Ordnung ist und dass man das jetzt ausführen kann.
Orpheus Ioannis Zafarisis, das bestimmt ein Griecher, oder?
Das ist auch der, der gerade hier offiziell am Stream so an ist.
Run anyway, bam.
Virus ist raus.
So, Venice unleashed, oder, oder, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen die korrekte Aussprache.
Die korrekte Aussprache ist ja eindeutig.
Ja.
Install.
Oh, vielleicht bisschen groß, die Immortz gerade.
Setup Wizard aus 1995.
Excellent.
Finish.
Da isser.
Oh, wow.
Startet einfach instant, lull.
Connecting zum Zeuss-Backend.
Okay, Moment, Moment. Mein Benutzername. Mein Benutzername ist...
Ich glaub' MaxSource oder sowas.
Passwort.
Remember me.
Login.
Was?
Oh, es ist noch nicht live, Leute.
Es ist noch nicht live.
Das Passwort ist richtig, 11h, ja.
Okay, wir lassen es jetzt einfach auf.
Wir lassen es jetzt einfach auf.
Bis es losgeht.
Und ich muss noch, ich muss wieder eine Runde Musik anmachen.
Okay, hören wir mal an. Was hat er denn im offiziellen Stream zu sagen?
Gleich geht's los.
Okay, also, das ist noch nicht live, aber ich kann eigentlich...
Hör' mal, lass mich...
Passchamp.
Gib' mir einen Sekunden, gib' mir einen Sekunden.
Ich...
Ich starte die Dinge live, damit ihr eigentlich anfangen könnt.
Ein.
Du kriegst keine Sekunde.
Go, go, go.
Wir werden das zusammen launchen.
Und hoffentlich geht alles auf Plan.
Weil das...
Es ist immer Spaß.
Gib' alles.
Was das ändert, ja, das kann man nicht so genau sagen, weil es hat noch keiner gespielt, außer ein paar Modder.
Im Großen und Ganzen kann man sagen, es ist ein Modding-Pack, also sprich, es gibt eigene Server, es gibt einiges an Mods, die bei Release da sind.
Es gibt Server bis 127 Spieler, bis, glaub, 120 Ticks. Müssen wir gucken jetzt. Ich hab' selbst keine Ahnung, genau.
Es geht? Es geht?
Ho!
Da ist es.
Guck' mal, ich hab' schon mal einen Soldier erstellt.
Okay, okay, okay.
Also, create new Soldier. New Soldier, cute, chat.
Chat, also wir haben zwei Varianten. Entweder wir machen cute chat als Soldier, oder wir machen den alten Klassiker...
Komm, wir machen den Klassiker, oder?
Wir machen, wir machen den Klassiker.
Der 6.
Okay, übelst fancy UI. Oh.
Excellent.
Okay, ich glaub', ich muss nochmal neu starten, alles klar.
Oh, was ist das?
Pausierungs-Champ.
Da ist er, der Informatiker. Kann man, kann man irgendwie...
Also, Servers.
Und, und was ist es? Killstreaks. Grandpa sagt Kills... Moment, Moment, Moment. Seh' ich das richtig? Grandpa sagt Conquest mit Killstreaks. Gib' mir Rush, Alter.
Okay, Settings, Master Volume.
Ich kann, ich kann keinen Conquest spielen, Alter. Aber das ist jetzt egal, wir joinen da jetzt einfach mal.
NOSHA TDM. Okay, nee, wir spielen lieber Grand Bazaar. Okay, Leute, ich mach' die Musik aus. Wir spielen lieber Grand Bazaar Conquest, bevor ich NOSHA TDM spiele.
Ey, es geht auch ohne. Warum soll ich das dann machen?
Okay, der übernimmt die alten Klassen, das ist schon mal nice. Oh. Wow! Alter, mein... Oh, es war grad ein Killstreak, der mich gekillt hat, vermutlich mal.
Oh, das ist viel zu laut, mein Ohr fliegt weg, Alter. Nein!
Ich muss leiser machen, Leute, ich muss leiser machen.
Lautstärke-Champ. Alter. Oh, Moment, Moment.
Mein Audio. Okay, okay, okay, okay. Post. Haha, null Post-Champ, Gegner am Starte. Alter, hüpf aufs Dach, dass ich was sehe.
Bashten, Alter, Bashten, Bashten. Huge Bashten. Basho-Sauro-Srex.
So, erstmal ne Runde. So, Killstreaks. Okay, okay. Ich camp jetzt mal ein bisschen, dass ich ein paar Killstreaks kriege.
Camper. Dude, mach ich jetzt. Hier, kriegste einen Midi-Pack. Alter, fliegt das weiter als sonst?
Killstreaks. Okay, die große Frage ist, Leute, wenn irgendjemand checkt, wie man Killstreaks, press the Killstreaks-Button in das Spawn-Screen to select your skills. Oh!
Ich muss erst im Spawn-Bildschirm Killstreaks auswählen, okay?
Das hab ich natürlich nicht gemacht.
Oh, oh. Okay, auf geht's. Wir gehen jetzt runter. Ich klau den jetzt in L.A.V. Easy. Easy L.A.V. Easy L.A.V. Klausur. Oh! Haha, Team Killstreaks.
Okay, muss man downloaden? Ja, 70, 77 MB musst du downloaden. Okay, also, ich soll hier angeblich Killstreaks... Ah. Grenades Smoked Adrenaline Rush.
Leute, komm, wir machen die High-Reward-Killstreaks. Oh, man kann mehrere auswählen. Grenades... Ach so, ich kann einfach alles auswählen. Okay, das ist natürlich auch eine Variante, ja.
Ich glaub, das sind wahrscheinlich einfach nur Test-Killstreaks. Es sind Scorestreaks. Guck mal, es sind Scorestreaks. Es sind gar keine richtigen Killstreaks.
Take Raid, wo sieht man das? Äh, weiß jemand, wie man FPS-Overlay machen kann? Das war irgendwas Traw FPS, ähm...
Wow, äh, was war das? Traw, Traw, nee, FPS, Render, Traw, FPS 1, ne? Yep, exquisite, excellent, excellent, excellent.
Äh, ich hab Squad-Sprint, das sagt, ich brauch Squad... Squad-Cover. Alter! Oh, was jetzt?
Okay. Ah, yes. F. Ja, gut, da kannst du nix machen, da kannst du nix machen. Reconnect. Webseite.com.
Okay, was sagt der, was sagt der Dude im Stream? Oh, oh, okay, das ist weg. It's back, it's back, it's back, it's back.
It's back, it's back. Nein, jetzt nicht back. Jet jebaited. Massive-Jebaited.
Dabei hätten wir jetzt gleich noch seinen ersten Killstreak gekriegt.
Poggers Runde, ja.
Ich meine, er ist zwar der Erfinder von Venice Unleashed, aber er muss mal Aussprache, Sprauchsprache üben.
Wir wissen alle, dass es Venice Unleashed heißt.
Ah, nice, da sind wir wieder.
Da sind wir wieder.
Servers.
Komm, wir sind die ersten, die wieder eingeloggt sind.
Oh, der Server ist glaub ich weg, kann das sein?
Okay, da war ein offizieller Streamer wieder aus.
Ist der Killstreak-Server weg?
Ich will unbedingt den Killstreak-Server, der war echt nice.
Äh, gibt's einen Refresh-Knopf?
Oh.
Some serious honkers, alles klar.
Kann das sein, dass das erst refresht, wenn man da...
Ah, man muss da ein bisschen rumklicken, okay.
Oh.
Er ist wieder crasht, er ist wieder down, er ist wieder weg.
Ah nee, okay.
Wo war denn der Killstreak-Server?
Sieht den irgendjemand?
Ach, hier.
Ah, ich glaube die haben gerade ein wenig, ähm, Stabilitätsprobleme, aber das ist zu erwarten beim Release.
Das hätte mich echt gewundert, wenn das jetzt einfach so funktioniert.
Guck mal.
Paintschamp.
Der nicht funktioniert, null.
Come on, you can do it.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, sogar Blizzard hatte beim letzten WoW-Addon wieder Probleme, da kann den ja wirklich keiner...
Okay, die Seite ist auch weg.
Einfach Modded Server.
Ja, und ein paar, und ein paar, äh, Enhancements.
Ton of people trying to get in.
Die haben, ähm, 120 Tick-Server oder sowas.
Oh, oh, geht's wieder.
Okay.
So we got a server list.
So these are all the servers that are currently live.
Some of them are 120 Hz, some of them are 60 Hz, some of them are just 30 Hz.
Solches Reconnect-Spam bis geht?
Some of them are not.
Man kann auch den eigenen Server hausen, ja.
Weißt du was verdächtig ist?
Niemand spielt.
Was im Endeffekt heißt, es kommt keiner gerade rein.
Dead Game.
Bad Idea.
Guck mal, bei ihm geht's auch nicht mehr.
MonkaS.
Ach nee, ich bin da gar nicht eingeloggt.
Macht nix.
Let me move this here.
Wenn deine Credentials falsch sind, dann sind die...
Ah, wir sind wieder da.
We are back, Leute.
Okay, backend seems to be somewhat stabilizing, which is good.
Das halte ich ja für ein Gerücht, dass es am stabilisen ist.
Ist bestimmt ein C++-Backend.
Okay, okay, das ist total überlastet gerade.
Oder Java... Oh Gott.
Hör mal auf.
Java-Backend.
If you're getting errors connecting, then just, I guess, just wait a bit and try again.
Backend is currently being hammered.
Nee, ich glaube, es ist Lua.
Ich glaube, das ist alles Lua.
Ich hab's irgendwo mal aufgeschnappt.
Oh.
Es macht was.
Maybe like a Pro-Mod.
Or something.
In the meantime.
Mach mal aus und wieder an.
Woher bekomme ich das?
Du gehst auf...
Venice-unleashed.net und lädst runter.
Das Problem ist nur gerade, dass die Website kaputt ist.
Hm.
Guck mal, hier Entwickler-Bonus.
Der kommt rein, ich nicht.
Sauerei.
Oh, login, login.
Post-Champ.
Pausierungs-Champ.
Es tut sich was.
Ah.
RNGesus.
Komm, komm.
Das sind sozusagen private Server, ja.
Nur, dass du halt viel mehr machen kannst.
Ho.
Okay, das ist RIP.
Das ist RIP, Alter.
Ich mein, immerhin.
Wir haben immerhin schon mal...
Wir haben immerhin schon mal Grand Bazaar gespielt.
Bis zum ersten Killstreak, ja.
Nee, RIP, RIP.
Da tut es nix mehr.
Das ist vorbei.
Ist ja fast wie unter Windows.
Tja.
Ist da Sebaro da?
Da ist Sebaro da.
Tja.
Ist da Sebaro da?
Der Sebaro hat sich doch so einen 64-kerne-Ultra-Server gekauft.
Sponsor den mal dafür, die.
Ich glaub, die Server selbst sind gar nicht das Problem.
Die Spiele-Server nicht.
Die, äh,
Game-Server für das Management,
äh, die Backend-Server für das Management sind wahrscheinlich das Problem.
Das sind Kills, das sind Scorestreaks.
Scorestreaks wie ein Kot, ja.
Also, was ich jetzt gesehen hab, ist, es gibt Granaten als Scorestreaks.
Es gibt ein Artillery-Strike als Scorestreak.
Irgendein Adrenalin-Rush, was wahrscheinlich so was wie ein Heal und schneller Schießen ist oder sowas.
Tja.
Genau.
Die hätten das mal alle mit Blockchain machen sollen, dann wäre das nicht passiert.
Dann wäre das nicht passiert.
Genau.
Ja.
Ach, die sind Single-Threaded, die Server.
Ja, dann.
sporty
du brauchst
Du brauchst kein Lizenzkey,
Du brauchst kein Lizenzkey, Du musst
Das steht in der FAQ bei denen auf der Seite, guck mal.
Ich würd die Seite auf machen.
Das steht irgendwo in der
in der FAQ drinne.
Das war Docs
Das steht drinne, dass du mit deinem Origin
Account
dich verknüpfen musst.
Aber das hatte ich wohl schonmal gemacht.
da tut sich grad nix
starten wir nochmal neu
ok wisst ihr was
ich erlaub dem firewall
typ jetzt
exes wurscht
dann ging es doch vorher auch aber
ja captain peng das haben grad alle
die sind ein wenig überlastet
enemy easy on 30 above
ich mein du kriegst wenigstens
ne fehlermeldung bei mir ist es einfach
bei mir ist es einfach unknown
ha
tut sich wieder was
aber wenn du im chat guckst
im offiziellen stream die spammen alle rum
is the news from another location
ok come on
gib alles
ok leute das erinnert mich fast
ein bisschen an den blizzard release
gut ne aber ohne scheiß
wirklich kein geflamme an die jungs
die konnten das wahrscheinlich vorher mit soviel
leuten gar nicht ausprobieren sich wahrscheinlich
keine ahnung 5000 leute zu connecten
jetzt häng ich im loading screen
top da war ich schon mal
du bist jetzt im server browser oh poggers
dann machen wir das einfach nochmal
airworker wie lang musstest du warten
in diesem loading screen
ich mein wir haben es ja eben gesehen es ging übel schnell
10 sekunden ok
du hast dasselbe
besta besta wallpaper
wobei bekomme ich den mod du gehst hier hin
den ist anleashed.net
und an download
das gehört captain peng
ich versuche es zu fixieren
an ein paar anderen probleme
und wir werden sehen
wie es geht
gib mir ein paar minuten
ich versuche zu sehen was wir hier tun können
warum ist das eigentlich
warum ist das eigentlich kein dark theme
kann man auf dark theme umschalten
wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist
macht ihr nichts draus mit account erstellen
wir können ja auch grad nicht spielen
egal egal
ich spiele jetzt keine normale runde ich will jetzt da spielen
oder nix
wo kannst du deinen origin account verbinden
das problem ist ich kanns hier nicht genau sagen
weil ich hab das wohl schonmal gemacht
2016 weil mein origin account war schon verbunden
aber du kannst es hier in der
FAQ seite angucken da stehts
guck
du musst
genau
du launch den klein
und dann sagst du create account oder
after you create your account
create your account and log
in to the venice unleashed client
und dann musst du das ganze
frag mich nicht wie das geht ich hab das wohl schon vor
uhrzeiten mal gemacht
vielleicht macht das auch automatisch
wenns läuft
wir sind mal wieder da
können wir wieder einloggen
und server
come on please
bless rng ach ne gibts ja nicht
mehr
ah er macht das automatisch
ok
ja
hören wir mal was der im stream sagt
ich werde jetzt einfach
und wisst ihr ja dass das ein problem ist
also das ist ein problem
das hatten wir auf der arbeit auch schon
wenn ein service down geht
will man ja eigentlich dass nicht auf einen schlag
50 millionen benutzer wieder drauf
ok das übertrieben
bei uns auf der arbeit sind es ungefähr 40.000
benutzer
du willst ja eigentlich nicht wenn der service down ist
wegen überlastung
dass dann instant wieder 40.000
ok rip
wieder instant 40.000 leute drauf kommen
und das problem ist
dass alle leute es so machen wie ich wenn das service down ist
reconnect reconnect reconnect
und alles was das macht ist
im prinzip noch mehr last erzeugen
auf einem service der eh schon
down ist weil er zu viel last hat
aber obwohl ich das
weiß ich kann mich nicht davon
bremsen
ich kann mich nicht bremsen das auch zu machen
hat jemand einen guten server
aber ja der sebaro hat so ein 30 millionen core ding
ha service
postchamp
ach komm an
es ging doch am anfang so schön
wir waren drin, haben unseren ersten kill streak gemacht
und dann
edu
er sagte
erzählen wir wie war es bis jetzt
ich habe 5 minuten gespielt
habe einen kill streak gemacht
den ich nicht auswählen nicht einlösen konnte
weil es gecrashed ist
so perfekt
ist das ein dlc
ist das jetzt ein komplett neues game
das ist eher so eine art dlc
also nicht wirklich
es ist eine modification am basis spiel
also du brauchst das
du brauchst das game
original
jetzt muss ich jetzt mal ein
passwort wieder tippen
ok ok ein passwort ja
ok rip
jetzt vorbei
jetzt habe ich auch diesen
komischen fehler
klein neu starten
ok starten klein neu
also wie gesagt ich mach den da gar nicht
ich find super dass es das gibt
ich beschwer mich nicht
pp hands
jetzt
was können die betreiber
denn so machen wenn die server so hart
überlastet sind. Es kommt drauf an, an was es liegt. Wenn es nicht am Server selbst liegt,
sondern vielleicht zu irgendeiner Connection sonst wohin, fragt mich nicht, dann könnte
man das ein bisschen upgraden, was auch immer. Vielleicht laufen sie auf irgendwelchen Cloud-Geschichten
und müssen einfach ein größeres Paket nehmen. Vielleicht können sie irgendwelche Optionen
tweaken, was auch immer. Oh Leute, wir können uns einloggen. Oh nee, es gibt nur noch keine
Staffer. Ja, okay, es bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig zu warten. Aber ist nicht schlimm.
Ist nicht schlimm. Was, 400 Mann sind drin? Wo sieht man das? Hat er das gerade gezeigt
im Stream? Ach, hat Norfeld gesagt. Okay, nice. Wie gesagt, ich kann auch noch warten. Ist
ja nicht wild. Niemand hätte erwartet, dass es laut ist. Guck mal, sogar Blizzard kackt
ab. Ich mache hier mal wieder aus, weil sich das sonst wieder rumspackt mit Use Another
Location. Gibt es eigentlich mal ein Update zum Schneestellen über die Baustelle? Gut,
die Baustelle ist keine Baustelle mehr. Ich wohne seit 7 Jahren in dem Haus. Oh, wir haulen
sowas von Tide, das glaubt er gar nicht. Das glaube ich ihm, das glaube ich ihm. Ich höre
keine Kniegedingse von ihm. Sowas? Also eins habe ich mittlerweile gelernt nach 10 Jahren
IT-mäßig. Du musst immer mit dem Schleppsten rechnen bei sowas. Es gibt keine Server, alles
weg. Also die Server sind mit Sicherheit noch da, aber der Master Server oder wie auch immer
die das machen, wird nicht funktionieren. Du musst immer mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen
und mehr. Das hat mir mal jemand in der Ausbildung gesagt damals, also schon ewig her, wenn mich
einer, und das hat sich im Nachhinein aber rausgestellt, der hat recht. Er hat gemeint,
wenn dich einer fragt, wie lange es dauert, dann nimm den schlimmsten Fall an und das
mal 2,5. Und das trifft bei vielem, bei vielem. Also sprich, wenn die sich überlegt haben,
ach wenn es hoch kommt, spielen das 1000 Leute, dann sollten sie lieber mit 2500 rechnen.
Ultimative Dice Experience, ja ist wie bei Battlefield 4 Release. Ist ähnlich, ja. Die
Musik im Hintergrund, ach die ist bei ihm. Der hat komplett recht, der Typ, ne? Der hat
komplett recht. Also dieses, was ich jetzt auch mache, dieses permanente reloaden, habe
ich euch ja gerade erzählt, ist an sich schlecht. Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal, ähm, sollten
wir uns einfach mal einen neuen Soldier erstellen. Ist dem das eigentlich unangenehm? Bestimmt!
Bestimmt! Ey, wenn du, wenn du einen Lounge-Livestream machst und dann ist, die hellste Slifer geht
es nicht. Natürlich ist einem das unangenehm. Lieber noch eine Runde, wie gesagt, ich spiele
nicht normal jetzt. Oder vielleicht, vielleicht doch. Ach, Create Salt, oh, was jetzt? Ah,
top! Wir könnten ja die Diablo Immortal spielen, in der Zwischenzeit. Die hätten die Q einbauen
müssen. Das wäre Big Brain gewesen. Immortal ist glaube ich Beta gerade oder sowas. Pause
Champ und dann immer Pippe-Hands, genau. So sieht's aus. Erst Pause-Champ und dann 10
Sekunden. Oh, null, W. Ah, ich bin eingeloggt. Oh, null, W. 400 Zuschauer, ja? Alle, alle
warten auf Battlefield 3. Und ich kann nicht spielen, aber ich bin ja beruhigt, der offizielle,
der offizielle Release-Stream kann auch nicht spielen. Loading Simulator, er ist nachher
wie bei Blizzard Release. Könnte man sowas im Voraus testen? Ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass sie das gemacht haben, aber einfach nicht mit zu vielen Leuten gerechnet haben und
halt das nicht getestet haben. Was, POC ist wieder klein im Chat? Ja, der Chat buggt,
der Chat buggt. Ok, jetzt kommt wieder Pippe-Hands gleich. Ey, Ddos bestimmt. Ich sehe die Hacker-Mans
in Stockholm schon sitzen gerade. Die Hacker-Mans in Stockholm. Es kann nicht sein, dass die
hier beliebter sind als unser Originalspiel. Erstmal alles Ddosen, chinesisches, indisches
Botnetz. Auf geht's. Stimmt, der Ddos von DICE funktioniert nicht. Zu schlechter Netcode,
zu schlechter Netcode für Ddos. Glaubst du, das wird heute? Ich habe keine Ahnung und
selbst, was ich glaube, ist vollkommen egal. Ich kann es nicht beeinflussen. Ja, dann müssen
wir denen doch mal ein bisschen Server-Sponsoren. Dein Server ist gecrasht. Geht die Website
noch? Ok, die Website geht noch. Leute, wir können uns glücklich schätzen. Wir waren
einer der ersten in Game und wir haben immerhin zwei Minuten spielen können. Ich gucke jetzt
einfach nicht hin. Ich gucke einfach nicht hin. Ich warte jetzt einfach, bis die Serverliste
geloadet ist. Und ich kann mir den Pepehands-Moment nicht angucken. Und wieder weggucken.
Ja, ich habe auch ein paar Kills gemacht, bis ich den ersten Killstreak bekommen habe.
Und dann war Crash. Catjam-Chat, wenn mal so viele Leute da sind. Zu der Musik kann man
eigentlich nur Catjam. Und geil ist es. Naja, wir haben zwei Minuten gespielt, schwer zu
sagen. Gibt es Custom Maps? Ja, potenziell schon. Die haben sogar einen Map-Editor.
Wollen wir mal in den offiziellen Discord schauen und gucken, was da so abgeht? Das
machen wir jetzt mal. Hier, da sind wir doch. Da sind wir doch auf dem Discord. Tja, wo
geht man jetzt hin? General? Release? Wo gibt es da? Oh, oh, guck mal, der Captain Peng
ist auch da. Alter, so viele Leute sind da am Start. Let's go. 1887 Leute online. Das
ist ganz schön viel. Wie viele sind denn bei mir? Hier sind es gerade 275. Die könnten
auch 1337 online haben. Ja, spammt mal nicht rum, sonst wäre ich noch gebannt. Die Leute
sind zum Spammen aufgerufen oder so. Bam, ist Kick. Feedback. Massive Game. Oh, da ist
jetzt einer ganz furchtbar lustig. Was? Ja gut, die wissen es ja auch nicht. Ich gehe
mal davon aus, dass die gerade wild am basteln sind im Hintergrund, dass es irgendwie tut.
Close. Ja, next. Oh, was jetzt? Wahrscheinlich einfach Timeout. Hören wir nochmal, was
der offizielle Stream sagt. Pass auf, den trollen wir jetzt. So, den Loading Screener,
den hatten wir auch schon eine Weile. Also, wenn man das beendet und macht neu auf, dann
connectet er neu und man kommt manchmal direkt in den Serverbrowser. Problem ist nur, was?
Wer ist in? Wieso hat dein Stream eigentlich den Tech-Ingenieurswesen? Weil wir hier
die Brain-Sachen machen. Du bist doch Informatiker. Was denkst du, wie das Backend funktioniert?
Alter, was weiß ich? Es ist wohl irgendwas in Lua. So was habe ich schon mitgekriegt.
Lua ist so eine Oldschool-Programmiersprache, die man früher für Spiele-Skrips verwendet
hat. Also nicht für das Spiel an sich, sondern für NPCs und Menüs und hast du nicht gesehen,
Lua ist echt abartig. Ansonsten, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich ist es was relativ
klassisches. Die haben irgendwo eine fette Datenbank stehen, denke ich mal. Ich denke
mal, dass Webseite und Game bzw. Webseite und dieser Client auf eine ähnliche Datenbank
zugreifen, weil die Webseite und Accounts und so müssen verbunden sein. Dann vermute
ich mal, dass sie eine eigene Kiste für die Webseite haben und irgendwie so eine Art Master-Server
für den Server-Browser. Ja, keine Ahnung. Lua ist nur für die Mods. Ich habe keine
Ahnung. Ich habe den Source-Code nie gesehen. Aber nachdem die Mods in Lua sind, ist die
Chance, dass der Server selbst in Lua ist auch ziemlich hoch und dass der Client in
Lua ist, glaube ich nicht. Wir können mal gucken, ob wir rauskriegen. Oh, oh. Oh nee,
jetzt hängen wir wieder in Loading. Ist er wie bei Wolcen-Release? Alter, Wolcen. Ich
weiß bis heute nicht, wie man Wolcen ausspricht. Der Client ist nicht.NET. Ich wollte nämlich
gerade mal probieren, ob man mit dem.NET-Decompiler irgendwie rankann. Wie, er kann spielen? Ah
nee, das ist der Trailer. Das ist der Trailer. Das ist der Trailer. 0W. Dezember 2020, korrekt.
Der Client benutzt Chromium Embedded für die UI. Ja, wundert mich nicht. Wer mag schon
gerne UI selber malen? Das ist einfach Trailer, der läuft, Lul. Wie kann man seinen Origin-Account
verlinken? Angeblich macht er das automatisch, wenn du beides offen hast. Äh, Null-Split-Hero
neu starten, aber es kann aktuell keiner spielen. Ich mache einfach einen Drittel der Battlefield
3-Viewer. Ja, der Witz ist ja, es ist ja nicht mal wirklich Battlefield 3. Battlefield 3
Loading Simulator mache ich gerade. Äh, Null-Split-Hero, da musst du wahrscheinlich einfach warten,
weil es geht bei keinem gerade richtig. Man kann Suppression deaktivieren, man kann den
Plaufilter raus machen. Komm, ich probier's jetzt mal mit dem anderen Soldier. Still
Pause-Champing. Ja, ich Pause-Champe innerlich schon nicht mehr. Ich P-Profette gerade eher,
als weil's nicht funktioniert. Der Typ ist geil. Oh, die haben den besten, die haben
die beste Keg-Emote am Start. Ist aber ein guter Server, guter Server. Fletcher, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Übrigens Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, heute an Subs. Danke an alle,
die es gesagt haben. Ähm, ich war gerade zu beschäftigt mit auf Reconnect-Clicken. Pause-Champe,
Pause-Champe. Wie ist so ein Ease Unleashed so? Ja, wenn man spielen kann, nice. Wir konnten
ganze 3 Minuten oder so spielen, dann ist alles gecrashed und seitdem geht nix mehr. Nico-CLS-Dankeschön
für 11 Monate Subscription. Du bist 1 vor Hyper-Sub hier. Die Musik erinnert mich an
Geek-Generator. Ja, kommt nicht von ungefähr, das ist halt 8-Bit-Gedudel, aber eines meiner
absoluten Lieblings-Soundtracks hier. Hoffentlich machen die Devs auch irgendwie, na klar, was
meinst du denn, die sitzen nicht einfach da und drehen Däumchen. Wenn man sowas launcht,
will man, dass der Kram funktioniert. Die werden im Hintergrund massig am Basteln sein
gerade. Gibt's da überhaupt Content? Es gibt schon einiges. Eben waren wir zum Beispiel
auf dem Killstreak-Server. Die sind richtig am Hackerman machen gerade alle. Ja, es ist
Fake-8-Bit-Musik, es ist 8-Bit-Musik mit modernen Tools. Auf dem Discord kann man den Stream
anschauen, wie er am fixen ist. Da gucken wir jetzt mal. Discord-Stream, wie er am fixen
ist. Wie guckt man sich Discord-Streams an, Leute? Wie geht das? Reize-Dankeschön, 7
Monate. Ich hab noch nie den Discord-Stream hier angeguckt. Du bist in den Channel. Ja,
ich ja. Leak-Releases? Nee, hm. Ach, in den da muss ich schreien? Da muss ich erstmal
ein Mikrofon ausmachen, sonst laber ich die hier voll. Und die Ausgabe auch, sonst schreien
die Leute hier rum. Und jetzt? Ah! Was? Was ist denn das? Was ist denn das? Was ist
denn das? Warum spielt der? Will er uns jibaden? Ah ja. Ok, gucken wir uns den Hackerman-Stream
an. Ich starte mal in der Zwischenzeit wieder. Oh, man muss das gar nicht vollscreenen machen.
Was sehen wir denn hier da? Fix me, fix me, fix me sehe ich da. Exzellent. Fix me. Das
erinnert mich an Ryan. Oh, T-Max, bester. Da weiß man schon, er ist ein echter Hacker-Man,
wenn der T-Max am Start hat. Ach, das ist ein VU-Server. Dann sowas, ja. Ey, hier gibt's
nichts zu sehen. Wieder raus. Aha, der Informatigor ist wieder am Start. Discord aus, da gibt's
nichts zu sehen im Discord. Unterlinux mit Ryan, ja, das habe ich schon gelesen. Das habe
ich gelesen. Ja. Ja, ja, ich habe das, habe ich, habe ich das gestern schon gesehen. Irgendeiner
hat es mir auf Twitter geschrieben. Oder hat mir einen Link geschickt und da stand dann,
es läuft unter Ryan. Filters. Ja, gut, ja. Was soll ich machen? Der zeigt den Jailer.
Okay. Er hört sich ein bisschen, er hört sich ja schon ein bisschen gestresst an, muss
man sagen. Übrigens Leute, nice, dass so viele am Start sind, aber wir können gerade nicht
spielen, weil es gerade alles gecrashed ist. Wo kommt ihr eigentlich alle her? Mal so eine
Frage. Kommt ihr über YouTube her? Seid ihr immer schon mal öfters auf Twitch am Start
hier? Oder habt ihr das gerade über irgendwelche Umwege über Twitch gefunden? Zufällig. Du
bist wegen der Sylvaner? Ja, verstehe, verstehe. Ja Leute, ich fürchte, das wird nichts mit
spielen. Können wir einen neuen Soldier kreieren? Cute Chat? Stunning, wie geht? Okay, Cute Chat
können wir schon mal erstellen. Stammgas seit 10 Jahren, das ist exzellent. Nee, das Server
Browser funktioniert nicht. Ja gut. Also Leute, wir werden das so machen. Guck mal, ich bin
jetzt fast eine Stunde on. MonkaS, jetzt startet der Server neu. Und wir werden einer der ersten
sein, der restartet, ich sag's euch. Wir machen jetzt zu und sobald der auf den Knopf drückt,
starten wir das Ding. Also ich sag mal mal so, ich bin jetzt fast eine Stunde on, eine halbe
Stunde bleib ich noch da, sollte nicht funktionieren. Weil ich sag mal so, also ne, ne, zwei Stunden
auf Refresh drücken müssen wir jetzt nicht. Der hat schon gestartet. Viewer-Rekord, nee,
kein Viewer-Rekord. Viewer-Rekord war mal bei irgendeinem Apple Livestream, da hatte ich
irgendwie 750 oder sowas. Jetzt probieren's alle. Bei irgendeinem Apple Livestream hatte
ich mal 750 oder sowas. Und da haben sich die Leute beschwert, dass ich, als ich mich
drüber lustig gemacht hab, ich weiß gar nicht mehr was das war, was hab ich mich lustig
gemacht? Über irgendeinen Trailer von Apple hab ich mich lustig gemacht, da waren die
Apple Fanboys am Start und haben im Chat quasi, wo hab ich das passende Emote quasi sinnbildlich
sowas gesagt. Die haben sich voll beschwert, das weiß ich noch. Wenn wir da beim Thema
sind, man sollte nicht zu viel fanboyen, hat man nix von. Also das einfachste was die machen
könnten wäre, aber das werden sie nicht machen, einfach alle blocken, irgendwo bei ihrem Anbieter
und einfach nur spezielle Leute reinlassen. Aber, das wollen wir ja nicht, weil es soll
ein Public Release heute sein. Okay Leute, wir kommen noch nicht mal mehr rein. Eben
sind wir immerhin bis zur Soldier Selection gekommen, aber jetzt kommen wir noch nicht
mal rein. Du kannst den sicherlich was donaten, ja ja, ich glaub der Community Fund gibt's
da noch. Kannste hier, musst mal gucken. Also wenn das gut funktioniert und wenn ich
da ein paar werde ich ihn auf jeden Fall auch was donaten. Da ist Please Fix Servers. Es
ist aber schon hart am echten Release dran. Wie kann man seinen Origin verknüpfen? Angeblich
macht er das automatisch, wenn man Origin und das gleichzeitig startet. Also gleichzeitig
anhat. Das mit den Donations ist übrigens auch so eine fragliche Sache, weil es könnte
sein, je nachdem wie die Benutzerbedingungen oder was auch immer es gibt, was von EA da
gilt, sobald man was verdient, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, kommen die vielleicht um die
Econ Vaults dicht machen. Es ist immer echt schwierig auch für Free Shards in MMOs Donations
zu nehmen. Max, kannst du uns erklären, warum das Projekt notwendig ist? Die Battlefield
3 Server sind doch immer noch online, weil du damit viel mehr machen kannst als mit den
offiziellen Battlefield Servern. Erstens ist Battlefield 3 offiziell relativ tot mittlerweile
und es gibt halt null Chance auf neuen Content. Und hiermit gibt's Map Editor, du kannst
eigene Mods machen wie z.B. Killstreaks, du kannst 120 Ticks Server hosten bis zu 127
Spielern. Sind diese Server auch bei Konsole? Nur PC, nur PC. Das ist PC only. PCMR. Ne,
das geht jetzt wieder nicht. Ja drin waren wir auch schon öfters, aber wir hatten in
der Serverliste nix drauf. Eingeloggt waren wir auch schon oft, aber man kommt nicht in
die Serverliste. Ja, der Chechi baited wieder, bin drauf, bin drauf, Serverliste voll. Ist
es endlich soweit? Ja, aber es geht nicht, weil alles gecrashed ist. Debate chat, debate.
Chat, ich bin auch drin auf dem zweiten Monitor und ihr seht's plus nicht. Er klingt ja mittlerweile
echt ein wenig verzweifelt, was ich aber auch verstehen konnte. Er hört sich echt verzweifelt
an. Was ist in den Weep-Ordner auf dem Desktop? Hab ich da ne Weep-Ordner? Ah, Chebat, lul.
Ok. Massive Chebat. Ist das so? Oh, oh. Woa. Ehh.
Alter. Ok. Refresh. Excellent. Operation Metro Conquest. Randomizer Rush Server.
Da gehen wir jetzt drauf. Was? Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Was? Nein. Ok. Huh? Huh. Things
are happening. Pro-Mod. Der RS-MGG funktioniert? Ok. Nein, es ist wieder kaputt. Es ist wieder
kaputt. Ok, Leute, ich geb, ich, also, ne halbe Stunde noch mehr, mehr, mehr, mehr Loading
Simulator mach ich net. RS-M Bazaar. Bam. Also man sieht ja, dass kaum einer spielen
kann grade. Was hat es mit dem 60 Hz und 120 Hz Aufsicht? Das ist wie oft das Server zu
dem Server Client sich updaten. Also wie oft das Server Updates verschickt. You're in
the server? Nice. Probably not gonna last very long unfortunately. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
My paperhands. Ich kann nicht mal Join. Chat sollte man jetzt Join können? Der Metro Server.
Das ist nicht so etwas, das sollte passieren.
Wie schwierig ist es, eine Login-Q zu machen? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich will sehen, woher diese Zerstörung kommt.
Dann schauen wir uns das mal an. Das Problem ist, dass, wenn ich noch eine habe, die UI für sie nicht da ist.
Das Problem ist, dass, wenn ich noch eine habe, die UI für sie nicht da ist.
F